the phone number requirement for Call of
Duty has been clarified and Gotham
Knights is getting an exciting new mode
Activision has clarified the SMS
requirement for Call Of Duty Modern
Warfare 2 confirming that a phone number
is required for PC players but not on
Console this confirmation comes not long
after another Activision Blizzard game
OverWatch 2 made headlines for its own
controversial SMS policy in a blog post
Activision said a quote text enabled
mobile phone number is required for
Modern Warfare 2 on PC this is the same
requirement that has been in place for
war zone players on PC since May of 2020
anyone who previously played Warzone on
PC won't have to do anything else to get
started with Modern Warfare 2 and
Warzone 2.0 additionally people on Steam
must link a phone number to play Modern
Warfare 2 so this requirement is not
limited to Battle.net alone the SMS
verification requirement is in place to
help with the anti-cheat efforts and
Activision added the requirement for
Call Of Duty Modern Warfare 2019 PC
players in August of 2022. Activision
also provided an update on the efforts
it's taking to fight cheating in Modern
Warfare 2 and Warzone 2.0 Activision's
Ricochet anti-cheat system will be
available at launch for MW2 and Warzone
2.0 and it will be beefed up with quote
better detection capabilities additional
access to develop and deploy new
mitigation techniques and expanded
freedom to update the security more
frequently than ever before during the
Modern Warfare 2 Beta the Ricochet
anti-cheat tools held the Activision ban
20 000 cheaters from the early test
additionally Activision banned sixty
thousand illicit accounts before the
beta even began Call of Duty Modern
Warfare 2 Launches on October 28th but
people who pre-order the game can start
playing The Campaign on October 20th
Activision is encouraging people to play
to its completion by offering special
bonuses and perks for those who complete
the entire thing and now let's talk a
little bit about Gotham Knights the
upcoming brawler set in the Batman
Universe will get a proper four-player
co-op mode in late November a little
over a month after the game's October
21st release called heroic assault the
mode will be added to Gotham Knights as
a free update on November 29th and is
entirely separate from the main story
campaign according to an FAQ on the
Gotham Knight's website the mode will
support up to four players online and
provides a dedicated arena-like
environment for specific objectives to
complete and enemies to defeat on each
floor there will be 30 floors total at
launch for players to complete this mode
will give players yet another way to
experience Co-op as the game's main
story only supports up to two players
heroic assault will allow for each of
the game's four playable characters to
fight crime together as a team in a way
that's not possible in that story mode
but it's Friday so let me know what
you're going to be playing this weekend
I just tried out Spirit fair for the
first time on Steam deck and wow I heard
it was a good game but like that game
that game is pretty adorable so I'm
going to be diving into that more this
weekend among other random things so let
me know in the comments and I'll see you
on Monday